[Musique]
à votre avis combien de temps il faut
pour faire remonter les besoins de tous
les habitants d'un village de 700
habitants il faut 35 heures avec une
équipe de quatre personnes
on l'a fait parce que avec judy ténès et
stéphane krajcik on est persuadé que
pour reconnecter les gens au collectif
il faut passer par le besoin individuel
et donc on a fait du porte à porte et on
allait voir tous les habitants du
village de l'es1 et on leur a posé
quatre questions
ces quatre question c'est qu'est ce qui
vous plaît dans votre village
à quelles activités ce que vous aimez
participer quelles activités il pourrait
y avoir de plus et qu'est-ce qui
pourrait y avoir de plus pour améliorer
la qualité de la vie dans le village
ces quatre questions sont basées sur une
méthode de psychologie positive qui
s'appelle l'anc est apprécié hâtives
c'est une méthode qui va mettre les gens
interrogés dans une posture
constructives plutôt que revendicatrice
les deux premières questions servait à
faire un état de ce qui fonctionne de ce
qui marche de ce qui va bien de ce qu'on
aime bien les deux questions suivantes
vont permettre de savoir ce que vos
courses qu'on veut construire de plus ce
qu'on peut faire de mieux ce qui peut y
avoir en plus par dessus ce qui existe
déjà et donc on a pris tous ces
résultats et on les a mis en ligne
ensuite on a créé une synthèse qu'on a
distribué dans toutes les boîtes aux
lettres pour que toute la population
monte en compétences sur le besoin
commun qu'ils puissent tous comprendre
quels sont les besoins des autres par
rapport aux leurs et donc vous savez ce
qui plaît aux habitants du village de
l'herbe c'est le calme la tranquillité
la nature la vie de village les
activités auxquelles ils aiment bien
participer c'est les activités du sou
des écoles et l'aller à vienne qui est
une course de randonnée qui a lieu
chaque année et ce qu'ils voudraient
avoir de plus c'est plus de convivialité
il voudrait un commerce de proximité il
voudrait plus de sécurité autour de la
départementale et plus de transports en
commun et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que quand on allait voir les gens
parfois il nous disait il ya bien un
truc mais mais ne notait pas sur votre
papier c'est un peu stupide mais je
pense ça serait bien d'avoir un dépôt de
pain ou un commerce de proximité mais le
noter pas le noter passé c'est un peu
bête c'est juste moi c'est pas grave et
quand je leur disais en fait que les 50
autres personnes avait dit exactement la
même chose
du coup leur visage s'éclairait
s'illuminait il sentait légitime dans
leur besoin d'un seul coup ils avaient
le droit de l'exprimer et c'est des
histoires comme ça j'en ai plein chaque
porte à porte chaque personne à qui on
va parler est différente elle va offrir
une vision de plus en plus riche du
territoire sur lequel on fait ça ensuite
on va organiser un atelier participatif
on va créer un espace temps où les
habitants vont pouvoir réfléchir
ensemble à la manière de répondre à
leurs propres besoins
l'atelier participatif de l'oea le thème
était faire battre ensemble le coeur de
notre village elles ont pu réfléchir
ensemble il ya des projets de jardins
partagés de cuisine collective des
projets pour améliorer la convivialité
d'un projet de commerce de proximité et
à chaque fois le maire qui était présent
avec quelques élus a pu se positionner
en facilitateur pour le jardin partagé
il a pu annoncer qu'ils avaient une
personne qui était décédé qui avait
légué son terrain à la commune et que ça
pouvait être utilisé pour faire un
jardin partagé pour le commerce de
proximité il a dit que le bâtiment de
l'ancienne station service avait été
nettoyée et que c'était s'était ouvert
on pouvait le prendre pour faire un
commerce de proximité et donc il ya
beaucoup de projets qui ont émergé et
ensuite on a fait un apéro parce que
c'est important aussi de célébrer le
travail qui a été fait donc on a bu un
coup tous ensemble et les gens ont pu
s'inscrire sur les différents groupes
projets pour savoir sur lesquels il
voulait contribuer ils ont pu s'engager
auprès des différents projets et un mois
plus tard on a organisé une réunion tous
ensemble pour infuser un petit peu de
méthode dans la gestion des projets pour
qu'il leur donnait des techniques
d'animation pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre que c'était tout à fait
possible de travailler ensemble de la
convivialité en s'amusant que ce ne
savait pas besoin d'être un fardeau et
au cours de cette réunion est né le
collectif collectif citoyen de l'oea
dont la mission est d' un fusée de
l'énergie et des ressources dans tous
les projets qui vont être dans le futur
dans le village est ce qu'on a fait là
c'est une méthode que l'on a créé et qui
s'appelle selon luc racine
c'est une méthode ouverte et partagé qui
consiste en quatre étapes la première
étape c'est réunir une équipe locale
la deuxième étape faire émerger les
besoins la troisième étape organiser des
ateliers participatifs pour amy imaginer
des solutions collectivement
et la quatrième étape accompagner les
projets qui sont nés cette méthode
elle est en open source c'est à dire que
tout ce qu'on fait on va le documenter
en ligne on va le mettre en libre pour
que tout le monde puisse en bénéficier
pour que cet outil sur un outil créé en
commun pour que les expériences locales
bénéficier au niveau global et que
chaque nouvelle expérience enrichissent
l'outil et en documents tous et ont créé
un kit qu'on va pouvoir déployer sur les
territoires on a déjà commencé
on a commencé avec le quartier
prioritaire de ferney-voltaire 1400
personnes on à evrard à abidjan qui nous
a contactés pour déployer un projet en
côte d'ivoire on a commencé à
accompagner alain auffray ce dans le
tarn qui voulait aussi déployer un
projet ce qu'on voudrait créer comme
monde c'est un monde où les élus
puissent se positionner en tant que
facilitateur des énergies locales au
lieu de porter sur leurs dos le poids de
leur commune ce qu'on voudrait c'est que
nous citoyens consommateurs du service
public on puisse redevenir contributeur
du bien-être commun et du coup j'ai une
question pour vous à votre avis combien
de temps ça prend pour faire remonter
tous les besoins d'un pays entier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]